und da ist es die krönung der schöpfung
aller ja der filter ist out regenbogen
glas version soll ich hab ich wieder was
auf reges und 2 der ungefähr ist endlich
fertig und genau wie monty fälle müssen
mehr dafür einfach erfolgen dann könnt
ihr den entwicklern story einfach
verwenden kein scheiß machen
ich habe übrigens fast 100.000 follower
voll nur wegen diesem einen push rote
100 ist auf jeden fall wenn euch jetzt
fragt hey was für ein ungefilterter das
ist der monte die schon erstellt haben
und genauso und instagram filter werde
ich jetzt auch führung herstellen und
genau wie bei montiert war hier der
erste schritt er ist ein richtig geiles
bild zu finden mit dem ich dann quasi
die textur machen kann und dann ist mir
direkt aufgefallen alter warum gibt es
entweder nur bilder in kartoffel
qualität oder bilder ohne brille hat und
gefühlt fünf jahre genau aussieht alters
davos da gibt es doch bilder aus 1980
und noch mehr bilder aus 1980 und wenn
man denkt okay dann suchst dir einfach
ein bild aus seinem video raus auch
schwierig weil er hat seine fans gehen
wir im team immer so klein wie meister
hatte seine fans können wir hier so
klein oder wenn die mal so groß ist dann
sieht es aus wie die elektrische gitarre
ich habe dann irgendwo in dem blog von
remy aus madeira bild gefunden das
einigermaßen gefasst haben dann wieder
so einen mist gestalt gezaubert ja das
muss dann so breit gezogen werden damit
es auch das 3d modell drauf hast musst
du nicht verstehen und dieses mal wollte
ich das mit der farbe bisschen fixen
weil jeder das habe ich jetzt glaube ich
gefixed indem ich die struktur der haut
erst auf des gesichts darauf gezogen
habe ohne irgendwelche farbe sondern nur
quasi mit den kontrasten und das ganze
sieht dann ebenso aus ja dann sieht er
nur ein bisschen hier so diese züge beim
bahn sieht man so ein bisschen die
details das habe ich erst mal damit
gemacht und dann auch wieder ganz
wichtig um das kopf ist so ein bisschen
den rundlich ja deswegen hier auch die
deformation genau einfach nur dass man
hier so ein bisschen ein rundliches
gesicht hat dann haben wir noch so ein
haut ebene die ziemlich viel macht das
ist eigentlich genau das was ihr euch
dann im vorjahr stabil gezeigt hat diese
gestalter in gestalt des sind gute name
alter umgestellt und dann habe ich es
auf der ebene also eingestellt was die
farbe noch nicht so krass von uns auf
meine haarfarbe abfährt und das ist
natürlich geil aber beim bad sollte die
fans schon ein bisschen krasser sein und
deswegen habe ich hier die bad und
augenbrauen noch ein bisschen nach
orange damit das land besser zu ihm
gepasst und dann natürlich noch der
verband würde der vierte bad der war
echt eine gute challenge beim kac hat er
mittlerweile richtig hätten vollbart und
das ist ein bisschen der challenge war
das nicht auf dem gesicht kann sondern
das muss ich als extra 3d objekt einmal
so rum schmiegen und das war tatsächlich
ein bisschen herausforderung die ich
dann aber relativ
hier ist der umgebaute ziemlich nah ist
wenn man jetzt und hier bewegt dann
traktor zum mikro wird ja das ist nicht
perfekt keine frage aber das ist mir auf
jeden fall meiner meinung nach zum
google und ich habe ja auch ein bisschen
versucht das ein bisschen ausgefranst zu
textur ihren auch schön nur hoffentlich
so das war die meiste arbeit dieser tat
das war auf jeden fall die meiste arbeit
was natürlich bei unmenge fehlen darf ja
ist die kopfbedeckung kopfbedeckungen
sind ziemlich wichtig man muss sagen
also diese gesichtszüge zu übertragen
ist ein bisschen schwierig aber was ich
machen kann machen was ich machen kann
ist die augenbrauen farbe was ich auch
machen kann ist so eine kopfbedeckung
und bei umgekommen hier nämlich zur
ungemütlich keine ungeheuer hielt kraft
ist heiß und geil auf jeden fall das ist
die mütze die junge gefühl noch einmal
zu dem stream trägt und hier ist das
kleine ungeheuer ich zeige euch mal ein
bisschen näher
ja hier so und die mütze ist eben auch
auf dem kopf darauf gedruckt und ist
auch in 3d modell was ich in autodesk
maya die modelliert habe und dann im
text wird habe genauso wie den bade- und
die gesichtsform habe ich alles in
meiner gemacht kult also die augen sehen
jetzt ein bisschen stranger aus ja die
guten noch nicht mal mit wenn ich jetzt
nach links rechts fehlern sind es ein
bisschen wild aus deswegen habe ich ja
noch ein bisschen komplizierter hier hab
ich habe die augen des nutzers
ausgeschnitten nochmal über die augen
hier drüber draufgelegt und dann quasi
ein kleines farb resort angewendet damit
es einfach besser auf die haut schon
angepasst apropos farbrollen ganz am
ende des videos machen aber ich hab'
leitung presets ausgebracht das sind
weil sie einfach voreinstellungen die
man einfach auf seine bilder darauf
ziehen kann und dann sehen die instant
geil aus habe ich mühe folgt er damit
möglich
geil aussehen hat sechs verschiedene
gesetze von venedig können möchte dann
checkt man den linken schreibung ab zum
launch gibt noch 20 prozent rabatt und
genauso ein paar priesterbild jetzt auch
auf augenhöhe sieht man ja es sind nicht
perfekt und man die leiterin research
und auf jeden fall geiler als das
passiert aber man sie jetzt auf jeden
fall die eigenen augen und die passende
habe ich auch so ein bisschen orange
lich ins haus rein weil wenn es nicht
mehr
dann wäre es hat einfach nicht so schön
und das ist er fertige ungefüllte
eigentlich müsste jetzt noch wurde
anziehen um die impression perfekt zu
machen finde ich ziemlich nah ist ja der
bart dazu setzt auf jeden fall die mütze
sitzt auf die fachleute jetzt fehlt aber
nochmals es wird auch viel geiler es
wird noch viel geiler es wartet noch
eine überraschung auf euch und zwar habe
ich mir gedacht was ist eine ohne seine
regenbogen lehrer habe gedacht okay wie
könnte ich diese regenbogen leser hier
in diesen filter einbauen ja es ist
natürlich schwierig solche jetzt einfach
vor die nase klemmen oder hier in mund
rein oder hier bei facebook wird dann
kann man übrigens auch was an die hände
strecken das wäre natürlich gewesen wenn
wir so einen regenbogen gassen in der
hand gehabt hätte instagram lässt das
alter nicht zu was instagram zulässt ist
folgendes jahr und zwar habe ich mir
gedacht okay als umgehe muss man
eigentlich immer sein wegen buntglas
parat haben man muss immer hier wasser
am hut er ihren muss man auch sein ja
immerhin stream und eine flasche leer
machen ganz wichtig und deswegen ja habe
ich mich von der ersten nummer 1
überhaupt inspirieren lassen
aber da vor bevor ich die erste nummer
eins zum leben erwecken konnte muss ich
natürlich erst mal die regenbogen gläser
machen ja das habe ich auch in majak
modelliert ja aber einfach so ein
zylinder gemacht habe dennoch ein
gemacht sagt gehabt dann die textur
gemacht ja ist ja ziemlich easy hamburg
gelb blau rosa ein bisschen rumprobiert
wie das am besten aussieht in dem
programm das auch so ein kleiner ist
eine kleine reflektion und natürlich
muss es auch personalisierte sein also
es keine coca cola habe ich natürlich
nicht gemacht weil es in der
markenwerbung wer und sogar muss nicht
zugelassen hat besonderen habe natürlich
gemacht weil es absolut geiler insider
ist also steht da jetzt die ruine
florenz weiter auf das gleich aussehen
werden sehen wir dann
ich hab sogar bei der bewerbung bei
instagram hero bindestrich in flörsheim
geschrieben damit die denken hero
influenza weil nicht dass dir denken
heroin
das kann man nicht nur dass man diesen
recht strengen was die richtlinien
angeht da muss man auch ein bisschen
tricksen ich finds auch
ich will nicht zu viel sagen weil sonst
nehmen ich finde noch unter null
ganz wichtig war auch die strohhalme ja
weil sonst lieber deine ganze nun sitzt
er will nicht die ganze zeit der flasche
trinken ich weiß gemusterten und immer
ins gym unterbrechen und leute ich weiß
wie sehr leidet ja ich weiß wie sehr
leidet und ich leide mit und ich habe
die lösung bringt strohhalm angeklickt
regenbogen gläser an seine mütze mit
strohhalm ansagen will der muss ich nie
wieder bewegen und um ganz mal ehrlich
wenn du das als merge verkaufen will ist
da können wir ins geschäft kommen dass
gar nicht so sehr auf den
feierlichkeiten nur ungefähr wieder in
europa vermutlich hier verschieben und
jetzt geht es wieder und da ist es die
krönung der schöpfung aller der
ungefiltert regenbogen glas version in
die regenbogen ja da kann man sich auch
immer wieder schön weil sie rein und die
auf würde dann nicht ist
[Musik]
mg
ist
da
alte mann hat den nördlich man hat den
bart man hat einfach alles die man sieht
aus wie die nummer eins ja muss man aber
sagen und sollte um genau auf dieses
video reagieren absolut geil ich bin
überhaupt aussehen wird schreibt ihm auf
jeden fall ist extrem absolut in die
kommentare ja letztens schon so eine
absolut geile support dagelassen ball
hat ihnen das in die kommentare wenn ihr
wissen wollt wie um mir mit dem gefährte
außenwelt und auch natürlich mit der
eiskaut regenburg ganze version ist ganz
wichtig werden wie gesagt jetzt selber
testen möchte und auch den anderen monte
feld und ein tanzverbot feld abonniert
mich auf ein ca
dann habt ihr einfach den fehler
internet euro freischalten könnt einfach
geile stories machen und neue freunde
werden sich denken ja was das für
behinderte aber markiert mich auf diese
story ich bin wie ich sehe was er damit
anstellt wie gesagt heute kommen eine
leitung priester zu hause also wenn ihr
eure bilder in stand richtig geil
graydon möchte und dass sie richtig geil
farblich aussehen und gar keine arbeit
ihr euch selber machen müssen weil er
frauen ihr seid dann könnt ihr euch das
linke ist eine wegbeschreibung zum
release gibt es 20% mit dem kot ich muss
ich noch einfallen das steht hier super
wenn ich auf dieser reise begleiten
möchte dann abonniert meinen kanal und
dann sehen uns beim nächsten mal wieder
macht's gut